your goals need to be really specific
with numbers and deadlines for example
increasing app downloads by 5% in 30
days you can use these goals as your
KPIs or key performance indicators for
the next few months this will help you
evaluate the success of your business
remember a KPI is a business metric that
you'll use to evaluate factors that are
important to your success each business
will have different KPIs for example a
clothing stores KPI
may be net revenue the government's KPI
may be employment rate wares for
abarkment our KPI could be the number of
sitters we have on our site or the
traffic we get to the site so to choose
these goals you'll want to start
thinking about the stage and the funnel
you want to improve on is your goal to
try to bring in more visitors here
you're going to want to consider traffic
so your goal could be to increase
traffic by 5 percent in the next 60 days
maybe your goal is to convert customers
to leads you can consider signups here
so your aim could be to obtain 15,000
signups to receive launch notifications
over the next 90 days or maybe your goal
is to convert leads to customers we
could consider enrollments here our goal
could be to enroll 5% of our leads into
our premium subscription or just turn
them into paying customers goals like
these are trackable and we can easily
tie them into our Google Analytics
account to track we'll discuss that
later in the course
ok so taking in what you've learned so
far about setting your marketing goals I
want you to revisit the two goals you
created earlier and change them to
reflect what you've learned now
challenge yourself with this but be
realistic you don't have all the money
in the world yet and your team is
probably understaffed fill in your
responses here